could the crew of the destiny have been
saved by a BC 304 traveling at
hyperspace ah I'm going to do some math
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so I googled this question just out of
interest and I got lots of different
answers people have been trying to
figure this out for a little while some
people say it could take only 90 days
for a BC 304 traveling in hyperspace to
actually go and get the crew of the
destiny so a rescue mission very
possible other people have said it could
take 8 000 years but I've taken a few
bits of information that we know from
Canon and try to figure out an absolute
minimum that it actually would have
taken for a BC 304 like the deadless to
go and save the crew of the destiny so
first of all we have to remember that
the Destiny was much much slower than
anything the deadliest could do
um it did travel at light speed but this
vessel was 50 million years old it was
built well before the city ships of like
the Atlantis it was built quite early in
the age
it was built for example much earlier
than the city ships like Atlantis
they could travel at a significant light
speed and Rush actually did say in SGU
that the destiny had traveled several
million light years from home so that
would require over 50 million years for
it to be traveling at a little bit of a
factor above that of light speed say 10
times light speed or something like that
however the BC 304 had Asgard hyperdrive
technology now that is significantly
faster than light speed so for example
the one thing that we do know is that a
bc304 travel from Earth to the Pegasus
Galaxy to Atlantis in 18 days so that
gives us a starting point to try to
figure out exactly how fast that vessel
is actually traveling and again this is
very rough and it's an absolute minimum
but
there is a real Pegasus Galaxy it is
roughly 3 million light years from Earth
so 3 million divided by 18 is
166.6 Light Years a day
or divide that by 24 and we get 6.9
million light years an hour so we
roughly believe that the deadliest can
travel at that 6.9 million light years
in our speed
so how far away was the destiny well
several billion could be
quite a few different things but let's
assume it's the absolute minimum that
Rush could have meant by several that
would be three so three billion light
years away so we take the 3 billion
light years three billion with nine
zeros divide it by 6900 which is how
many light years an hour the um
deadlifts can do that gives us 43
478 hours
we divide that by 24 to give us 1811
days divide that by four again to give
us 4.9 years so it's an absolute minimum
if the destiny is only 3 billion light
years away it would take at least 4.9
years for the deadliest to reach it now
that's assuming we know exactly where
the destiny is and they don't have to
search for it that's assuming that this
vessel the BC 304 can actually travel in
hyperspace without stopping
which it can't so we're assuming the
destiny is the absolute minimum distance
that they don't have to look for it and
the Daedalus doesn't have to stop and it
would still take 4.9 years to get there
so a 10-year round trip to save the crew
of the destiny now we also think that
the BC 304 could potentially tow the
destiny but is it worth trying to
actually rescue the technology I would
argue not the Atlantis is a far more
advanced vessel than the Destiny was
so from a technological point of view it
would be interesting to an archaeologist
is it funny to consider that an
archaeologist would be looking at the
destiny interested that it's a
technology that's still way and more
advanced than we are today but actually
for sg1 it would be dated
however the information aboard the
destiny would be interested so a crew
could within the destiny go to the
destiny download some information scan
the destiny etc etc pick up the crew and
come back but that mission would take a
minimum of 10 years
now several can mean anything imagine
actually that when Rush said several he
actually meant say six billion
well in that case we're talking about a
10-year trip and a 10-year trip back so
20 years to go and save the crew of the
destiny now I'm sorry
a five-year trip would not be considered
I think a viable Mission plan
10 years not a chance and then like we
say that is an absolute or minimum based
on many assumptions that to be honest
are gonna be low ball
so could a BC 304 go and save the crew
of the destiny not a chance
it's physically possible but no way
who's going to give up 20 years of their
life to go on that mission you could
maybe send it automated but then you've
got to find them so again not likely but
guys get into the comments and tell me
what you think is my math any good
because math is not my best subject I'm
not great at it I've tried to keep this
as simple as possible because I know I'm
not very good at it but what do you
think am I weighing off with any of my
estimations
I think I've lowballed this but you guys
tell me I might have made horrific
mistakes here get into the comments and
explain it to me if I did
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us anything
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our videos first and for small
contribution each month that really
helps the channel out and does mostly go
directly to me and the channel you can
see it without the adverts
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]